Stanly is far from the only person to
make a Marvel cameo in fact many of the
most interesting MCU cameos come from
people whom casual moviegoers may never
have heard of or expected to see in a
superhero movie Avengers endgame is a
massive film packed with details
everywhere you look but some of its most
exciting tidbits and Easter eggs arrived
not with the big action spectacles but
with the quiet moments early in the film
Steve Rogers aka Captain America is in
New York City attending the support
group for people still struggling to
find a way to move on after that os--
wiped out half of all life the scene
mostly revolves around a man played by
end game co-director Joe Russo
explaining a recent date he had but if
you look at the people sitting in that
circle you'll notice a bald man with a
goatee
that's jim Starlin an extremely
influential comic book writer and artist
who's best known as the creator of
Thanos as well as Drax and Gamora among
many others and the author of the most
important Thanos story the Infinity
Gauntlet the tale in which Stannis first
snaps his fingers to wipe out half of
everyone so Thanos says snap did not
erase the man who dreamed him into
existence every Marvel Cinematic
Universe film is packed with Easter eggs
callbacks cameos and other details you
can't possibly absorb on the first watch
the guardians of the galaxy films are
particularly packed even when compared
with other MCU releases writer director
James Gunn is particularly committed to
his Easter eggs and cameos and as a
result the guardians flicks are full of
them
some like Nathan Fillion appearance as a
prisoner in the first guardians film are
fairly well known others are less so in
part because they often take the form of
seemingly random voices in a
post-credits scene from guardians of the
galaxy volume to the ravager leaders -
car is looking to reform his old team
which is made up of members of the
original guardians of the galaxy whose
Marvel Comics origins date back to 1969
among them is a robotic head named
mainframe who is voiced by none other
than Miley Cyrus Miley Cyrus isn't the
only music star to cameo in the
guardians of galaxy universe in the
first bill we hear a voice on the
ravager ship dubbed the ravager
navigator
fifteen minutes
that voice could have been anyone
including some random member of the crew
but since this is a James Gunn movie he
managed to use the voice of one of his
friends this time around it was rock
star and director of House of a thousand
corpses and The Devil's Rejects Rob
Zombie God explained Rob's a friend and
he appeared in my first movie slither so
now it's become my signature but I love
putting a lot of stuff in my movies for
fans and slither every street sign
referenced a classic horror film there
were hundreds of them I'm in service to
those people who want to watch a movie
again and again
zombie also made a cameo as an unseen
ravager and guardians of the galaxy vol
2 an x-men Days of Future past
sentinel inventor Bulevar Trask appears
before a congressional committee to
discuss his solutions to the perceived
issues stemming from the mutant
population the Congress men are divided
in their opinions with some believing
mutants are largely peaceful and others
claiming they're a legitimate threat one
of the congressmen arguing for peace is
Chris Claremont the undisputed most
important x-men writer ever we have very
real enemies out there the Russians the
Chinese Claremont took over uncanny
x-men in 1975 and remained the series's
writer throughout the rest of the 1970s
and 80s also co-creating various
spin-off series and standalone graphic
novels along the way many of the
greatest x-men storylines ever including
Days of Future past
God loves man kills and the Dark Phoenix
saga for his creation and he co-created
x-men characters ranging from mystique
to gambit to Jubilee he also made a
cameo as a man mowing his lawn in x-men
The Last Stand but in Days of Future
past he actually gets some dialogue
Claremont's not the only major figure
from superhero comics to appear in Days
of Future past he's not even the only
major figure from superhero comics to
appear in that congressional hearing
scene one of the other congressmen who
at one point argues with Claremont's
character is none other than lanuit
another pivotal figure in the history of
the x-men and in superhero comics as a
whole we haven't had an incident in over
10 years after what happened in Cuba
that was difficult wean is a key figure
in the histories of both Marvel and DC
Comics he was Marvel's editor and chief
for a brief period in the mid 70s and in
1975 he was the writer tasked with
reviving the x-men a team that had been
relegated to reprints for several years
at that point
working with artist Dave Cockrum we
devised the strategy to bring the team
back with a new group of international
members he soon handed writing duties
over to Claremont's but reen's jolt of
energy at this pivotal time in x-men
history was critical it was also a vital
character influence on the make up of
the eventual core team having co-created
Wolverine storm Nightcrawler Colossus
and more for a very long time in the
world of comic books James Buchanan
Bucky Barnes was a character you could
count on to stay dead alongside former
Robin Jason Todd and Peter Parker's
Uncle Ben he was Captain America's World
War two pal but cap had to move on
without him as he tried to exist in a
new era then in 2005
Bucky returned as the Winter Soldier a
Soviet assassin with a metal arm the
storyline became one of the most popular
and acclaimed Marvel Comics runs of the
2000s and ultimately made the leap to
the big screen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe these days Bucky Barnes is one
of the MCU fandoms favorite characters
so it's only fitting that at least one
of his creators should get a little nod
on the big screen and Captain America
the Winter Soldier during one of the
scenes in the Hydra lab you'll see
writer Ed Brubaker who co-created the
Winter Soldier with artist Steve Epstein
helping to work on Bucky as Alexander
Pierce interrogate him Marvel Studios
first Thor film was teased at the end of
Iron Man 2 with a post-credits sequence
that featured agent Phil Coulson finding
the god of thunders hammer embedded in a
crater in the New Mexico desert that
crater creates an interesting bit of
chaos and
as the locals find the hammer and start
taking turns trying to pull it out of
the ground before shield manages to
quarantine it
this of course culminates in the moments
when a man played by Stanley himself
tries to yank the thing loose with a
truck it doesn't work before Lee's truck
antics no another Keith or Ryder
attempts to private hammer out of the
ground J michael Straczynski author of
an acclaimed and influential run on the
Maine Thor title in the late 2000s
making him one of the biggest names
associated with the character around the
time the film was made Straczynski isn't
the only major for Ryder to make a cameo
in the MCU later in the first Thor film
after the battle on Midgard is one lady
SIF in the Warriors three are
celebrating their victory with a feast
and the halls of Asgard as wool stag
tells an amusing story about their
exploits the camera cuts the lady SIF
and an unnamed Asgardian man as they
laugh in response that man is Walt
Simonson and if anyone has the right to
be hanging out in Asgard with the
Warriors three it's him Simonson is
perhaps the most influential and
acclaimed for writer artist of all time
thanks to an epic run on Thor from 1983
to 1987 which introduced many of the
series's most popular supporting
characters and storylines including beta
ray bill and that time Thor got turned
into a frog his fingerprints are all
over the various Thor films and his
impact is still felt in four comics
today some Marvel movie cameos happen
because the person making the cameo is a
recognizable movie star who might get
the crowd excited others serve as
tributes the comic book creators without
whom the characters and storylines
featured in the films would not exist
then there are those blink and you'll
miss them cameos that make it look twice
because you're not sure if you saw the
seemingly random celebrity or just
someone who kind of looks like that
that's the case with one particular
cameo in the MCU movie that started it
all Iron Man as Tony Stark fires up his
first-ever Iron Man armor to stage his
escape from the cave where he's been
kept prisoner his arc reactor shines
onto the face of a seemingly random
terrorist who was then quickly swatted
away that early victim of Iron Man was
Rage Against the Machine and Audioslave
guitarist tom morello who later
confirmed his involvement on social
media
in Deadpool to Deadpool decides he needs
to put together a super team to pull off
his new mission of stopping cable he
assembles a group of mutants and a guy
named Peter for the job including
dominoes shatter star bedlam man someone
called the Vanisher the Vanisher is
appropriately named because we almost
never see or hear him he's just an
invisible presence in every scene and
until the moment when X forces parachute
jump goes horribly wrong and several of
the would-be heroes die gruesome deaths
the Vanisher still attached to his
parachute flies into some power lines
and is electrocuted at the moment the
electricity touches him we see that the
banister is actually Brad Pitt it's a
split-second cameo but one of the
biggest surprises in all of superhero
cinema how did it happen
well according to screenwriter Paul
Wernick Ryan Reynolds himself reached
out to Pitt whose kids are deadpool fans
after they agreed it would be funny to
get an extremely difficult to book actor
for the cameo and the rest friends is
cinematic history so the movie is in
there for just a quarter of a second it
graduated vanished or any-any
unfortunately dies by electrocution pimp
Pitts isn't the only a Lister to make it
difficult to spot cameo in Deadpool 2 at
one point in the film cable approaches a
pair of locals as they're having a
discussion in the back of their truck
about of all things toilet paper the
point of the scene narrative Lee centers
around cables stealing the truck but
it's also a platform for some hilarious
dialogue about the inadequacy of toilet
paper toilet paper is plenty for an
appetizer but then
Huggies natural care whiplash that's
humane course one of the men in the
conversation is fairly easy to recognize
his fireflies star alan tudyk the other
under heavy makeup is matt damon
deadpool - director david leitch later
explained how they pulled that off
saying bill Corso our makeup artist he's
a master at prosthetics
he had Matt in the chair for three hours
and a lot of the crew didn't know there
were some people who had worked with him
on movies but we didn't even tell the
crew his name wasn't on the call sheet
it was a fake name nobody really knew
what that scene was about they were like
why are we shooting these two rednecks
we just didn't tell anybody check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorites topper coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
you